yo it's baby drill I'm coming up on the
bootleg Kevin podcast
that's not the plan
all right man look bootleg cash show we
here we got a special guest uh he's got
a big show at the novo is it Thursday
night yeah with nudie uh of course baby
drills here welcome sir
how you doing man skirt
um welcome how's La been treating you
did you go to BT awards no I got here
too late for [__] it was but I've been
dreaming smooth everybody tapping there
yeah
um how long you been rapping like would
you would you like kind of start like
you know recording taking this [__] real
serious probably a year and a half ago
it's not very long ago yeah
so you started like actually recording
for the first time a year and a half ago
yeah about two years ago at the max two
years but probably in half though so you
got you got locked up and then your
joint went crazy while you were
incarcerated right yeah but it was going
crazy when I was up but it was it was
crazy when I got locked up yeah what was
like uh I mean for you like because that
was a 32 Freestyle right yeah
which number song was that for you was
that like one of your first like records
that you laid down or before one little
one that popped me off yeah that's the
one that changed things for you yeah it
changed everything
you get out of jail things are different
most of them but I had a song with two
though so like that was it was back and
forth from 32 freestyle to that side
how did you do the uh link up that's
fine my family my dog
like family family or like I'm saying
like how do I end up initially you know
Family Blood coming close did you guys
uh for you like seeing like what him and
21 were doing did that like motivate you
to like really start taking the Rapture
serious because I mean not everybody's
got those opportunities with those
relationships you know yeah made me feel
like it's possible from a [__] that you
know something
they didn't know a [__] like they can
do it yeah it's like yo if I see
somebody from where I'm from doing it
it's very possible hey
uh what would you say influence wise
like your sound like how you rap what
would you say your biggest influences
are
oh no I ain't all silence I just created
my whole sound so like
I wrap off emotion though so most dude
be like
I have a feeling yeah well would you go
up listening to how about that
every [__] duh
Savage baby
Gucci
would you say because I I always talk
about this do you think
who's the like
god of the Trap [__] because it's Gucci
tip or Jeezy I feel like it's one of
those three in terms of just like
yeah the greatest a r in hip-hop history
I say yeah
[__] [__] couldn't do that's so hard
did you uh for you uh because you kind
of how old are you if you don't mind me
asking 21. yeah so you're 21 so you were
like a kid like Pete Gucci like a small
child you know what I'm saying so I
really listened to the rappers no yeah
you're saying my errors the [__] just
that's popping right now yeah that's
what I'm saying 100 man
um somebody like uh coming up under
someone like nudie Nudy's obviously
somebody who I feel like doesn't get
enough flowers in terms of just his
influence his catalog is so crazy
um is there something that he has taught
you that you apply to your whether it's
music shared maybe a live show [__] how
you record anything like that yeah
stay down
oh yeah I do stay there yeah he's
definitely
I feel like Nudy's definitely got his
fingerprints over a lot of hip-hop right
now we got it we gotta you know start to
acknowledge you know what I'm saying
what about Savage
yeah
he's giving you any advice yeah just
right choices decisions and [__]
what were you locked up for if you don't
mind me asking
um
but you're out yeah
congratulations yeah
um going through something like that
where you might like lose your freedom
does it kind of
you know make you appreciate
life a little bit more does it kind of
change the way you look at certain [__]
because like I can only imagine you know
your life might be over if it goes the
other way like uh it might get
appreciate a lot of [__] though
maybe Sneezy got a lot of time to think
right yeah so you appreciate everything
we appreciate the food especially when
you see what the [__] they feel what are
the earlier because like we always hear
people like will make their own spread
and [__] in prison right like you'll get
your own [__] and make it but like the
actual food that they give you is
terrible right yeah [__] look like it
okay
but I've seen like also videos where
people are making like Hibachi Benihana
type [__] this is down the road yeah
this news already don't call time like
them [__] you know what I'm saying
when [__] in the county today no
County Jail there's not too much you
could do right because you're not you
don't know but you're right [__] Ain't
just gonna be cooking Hibachi no no
[__] my can get something about you
like the real thing before a [__]
cookie
what is
did you learn how to whip up a nasty
like a good spread in jail yeah what are
you putting in the spread
cooler Kool-Aid in the spread
all right bro you mess everything up all
this [__] go together
it don't matter is it ramen noodles
involved with the Kool-Aid well I'm
losing while every time with every meal
in them offer
do you find yourself
eating spread still because I have
homies who did a lot of time and they
get out and I'll go to their house I'm
gonna make a packet and they're still
eating like they're in jail yes because
they're like bro it's good what do you
want from me like it's good and it's
cheap
a pocket yeah so it's because you put it
in a bag right yeah and you just whip it
up and then no this this should take
more to just whip it up
all right listen I'm on vacation we're
cutting commercials live from Mexico
we're on the beach damn it so check this
out man don't forget it's summertime you
gotta go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg all
right that's gonna get you a free month
supply same active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis of course uh the best part
about Bluetooth is it gets your dick
super hard what are we talking about
all right if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction do the stress do
the
I don't know whatever is going on
mentally it happens too you can get that
Ed fixed Bluetooth
promo code
bootleg three month supply bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to the family at
Odd Socks baby that's right shout out to
Odd Socks they got all kind of crazy new
licenses they just dropped uh man
Transformers they got the Hasbro
licenses now Power Ranger sucks of
course they just did the Coca-Cola
earlier this year of course the most
comfortable socks in the world go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and save 20 off
oddsoxofficial.com
um all right for you man obviously
you got a big show I said Thursday in LA
doing the Nobles a big deal man that's a
that's a venue that a lot of people have
blessed on their way up you know what
I'm saying
um do you get nervous when you got a big
show like that to see you like La it's a
little different from being in a I mean
I just did break that bad
which obviously is crazy but it's home
you know what I mean I mean yeah I mean
[__] 21 he he headlined that too yeah
yeah but I don't think I ain't sure I
did it so I can't really say but I'm
gonna be nervous I'd be happy as hell oh
good how was Birthday Bash
did you grow up like going to any of the
other birthday bashes wow I'm from
Atlanta that was my first time going
coming from Atlanta
do you automatically adopt the sports
teams
like are you a Hawks fan
with all teams and I just know that's uh
are you more like a players guy like
your formula player uh for the player
before too so who are your favorite
players right now
um
they got all suited up on 2K
I mean and also real life yeah but you
know I planned it on 2K let me go crazy
he's really good on 2K I heard he's good
on Call of Duty too
um
[Music]
I feel like driving rain is going to end
up I feel like Nudy's gonna end up
signing John Moran before it's all said
and done you know what I mean if you
come over come on with it
yeah I think you know who else is a good
rapper slash Ballers uh miles Bridges
miles Bridge is a solid
he's not bad he's not bad you know also
probably could use a record I think he's
signed a Sada baby so I guess he's
already gotten taken up you know so you
like drama are you a Trey young guy
young Katie Carrie Luca Lucas he's gold
piece right yeah who is the goat
um it'll be hard in paper it's LeBron
James
well I mean that's unfortunate that
you're not that smart
if you want huh you want I thought he
got swept he's to go I mean he's 40.
you know what I'm saying that's uh it's
I mean I think LeBron might have a child
older than you I could be wrong but you
do
what I mean I'm just saying he's like an
old man he's been doing it so long
you know so you don't think LeBron is
the goat no what about Jordan but you
have never seen Michael Jordan play
basketball so I guess we really can't
even say that right you saw him on
YouTube
okay so who's your goat
me I should have been putting me in the
down NBA you were to go
you're the goat yeah yeah hmm I'm trying
to think since you've been like
um
oh I'm it's probably for your generation
like low-key it's probably honest
oh yeah
yeah
Giannis is probably in the last 10 years
you know it's probably honest you know
probably the best player the last decade
or so what do you think about Nicola
jokic that big goofy white man
pretty hard to yeah it's hard to stop
him
yeah but y'all yeah shout out to John
man John's gotta [__] stay off
Instagram you gotta take take his IG
live away and he'll be all right
um what do you got coming man I know you
just dropped a song in a video today
right yeah I'm good can you smoke the
jokes
what are you working on what's coming up
um
getting [__] together I just dropped
tape but you know Nick can't stop work
it's non-stop pressure
all right you already know man we got to
stop the interview shout out to my
bookie right now if you go to my bookie
and sign up man I was just playing
roulette like live with a real person
spinning the ball on webcam at the
casino
mybookie.ag you can of course bet on
baseball
but really you got to get down with the
casino they got the slots they got all
the card games Blackjack cracks uh
roulette table games galore it's a
full-fledged casino mybookie.ag and when
you sign up with that promo code bootleg
sign up right now use that promo code
bootleg they're gonna get you hooked up
with the first deposit bonus
mybookie.ag let's get back to the
interview now if you guys don't know
about King pong kingpong is all natural
baby yes all right we're talking about
the leader when it comes to uh
tobacco-free natural organic Leaf wraps
if you're a smoker a toad or a straight
west coaster you know what I'm saying
whatever you're into King Palms they got
it for you what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying and then you got
flavor I'm going to show you what it
looks like when it's stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms maybe you already know what
it is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout half
off at checkout fifty percent off if you
go to kingpom.com and use that promo
code the promo code is down below go run
it up try some of these flavors too man
the peach pineapple the Strawberry
Shortcake they just got so much going on
there's also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview how much like for you how much
unreleased music are you sitting on at
any given time like what's on the hard
drive you got you already got like a
whole lot of [__] ready to go or you
kind of work on a project for a project
basis no I probably got
as soon as I got a I was a studio every
day it's cooking yeah I was a houseman
so I couldn't go nowhere but the studio
were you able to go like probation let
you go to the studio that's all the
worst I could go yeah I heard if you're
on house arrest did you have the
bracelet or the the ankle thing right
yeah I had the real one you can't book
on I heard you uh you also can't take
baths in that excuse me you can't soak
it you can't soak it so you can't swim
you can't like get in a hot tub like
showers only you don't need no hot tub
you should getting hot tub it was winter
that's why you should get in a hot tub
during the winter you got to get in the
hot tub you got to eat mushrooms that's
not that's not a thing that we do have
you ever had shrooms yeah so you got to
do shrooms yesterday nice
[__] I might be on some right now
no micro dose
have you ever ate shrooms and then got
in a hot tub and looked at the stars
when you were on shrooms yesterday what
were you doing on the shrooms like what
were you what was your environment I was
in studio
so you like to be on shrooms while
creating yeah that's okay the process
you got a lot [__] you should never
think about like damn that [__] sounds
too hot yeah however have you ever had a
bad trip
um well you had too much and like [__]
maybe you saw so I mean you know
sometimes people have bad trips on the
streets no I had a bad trip on the
airport but not sure I'd be cool well
eating weed is much more dangerous than
eating mushrooms I tell people if you
eat too much weed
it could be rough
what was your bad trip on edibles
I feel like everything okay in there I'm
sick in there did you puke no it's a
were you hallucinating
yeah that's what it is this is loosening
would you see that wasn't there you just
felt like every I mean
the walls was like coming in and that
was so I was you know so I feel like the
Soulful evening I would fall into the
sofa oh yeah yeah how much do you know
how much you ate like how many
milligrams hell no that's the one thing
about those if like you just get your
Edibles from your homie you never know
how potent or not potent they'd be like
you know like you could you know when
these elements don't ask like how much
in this
let me eat it and we'll deal with we'll
deal with the day how it comes you know
what I'm saying
did that scare you from doing Edibles
again
they're terrible you should never do
Edibles just eat mushrooms still
assignment yeah just just trip hard and
make music yeah
uh all right man we'll look uh you said
tapes out performance this Thursday you
just dropped the music video today
um anything else uh on the way they want
to talk about
whatever
uh well look man Thursday Novo Los
Angeles make sure you pull up baby drill
we appreciate you pulling up man what's
up what's up good to meet you buddy yes
sir boom I appreciate y'all watching
another interview brought to you by our
good Folks at hardean now listen y'all
when you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell him to take you to
hardine the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection to premium cannabis
you'll see period anywhere let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you will get the best experience the
best customer service the best bud
tenders you walk in the hard Dean and
that [__] just smells amazing they got
their own [__] scent literally you
get into my car I got a bottle of it my
car smells like Harding because it's
just the best [__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're going to take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to hard Dean all right you got
to go [__] with hard Dean man Harding
underscore Las Vegas uh thank y'all man
I love these guys they're like family to
us and uh hey we're gonna drop another
interview soon if you're watching this
you're at the end of the interview
though much love